okay next question today David how do
you feel about victims using libel
lawsuits against Alex Jones in order to
get him to recant on his lies and
misinformation that he has been
propagating I have no problem whatsoever
you know Donald Trump campaigned on
opening up libel lawsuits to make it
easier to sue media outlets we have an
infrastructure right now for libel
lawsuits that is really pretty strict
when it comes to successfully suing
someone for libel and part of it is that
your life was in some way a materially
damage and that is why it is difficult
for celebrities to sue random people on
Twitter for libel because even if they
are saying untrue things about the
celebrity the celebrity's personal
profile is such that they're not
actually going to be damaged they're not
going to lose work as a result of the
comments that are being made their lives
are not going to be maturely altered in
any way you really have to demonstrate
that they were in order to win a libel
lawsuit and along the same lines the
idea of the frivolous libel lawsuit
against Alex Jones is effectively a
misnomer or a myth like the Sasquatch or
Loch Ness monster because if it's really
a libel lawsuit without merit it's not
going to go anywhere and if it is a
libel lawsuit that has merit then why
wouldn't you be able to actually use
that as a mechanism to get Alex Jones to
stop spreading lies or misinformation
whether it's about comet ping-pong or
Chobani yogurt or whatever else it is
that he's had problems with so I have
you know I think that the indirect
question might be do I believe that it's
an attack on free speech to use a libel
lawsuit against the media person and I
think the answer is no my concern about
Donald Trump loosening the requirements
for successful libel lawsuits would be
concerning to me in terms of the
infringement on on free speech but it's
very narrowly defined right now and I
don't think that the libel lawsuit as it
currently exists is a way to spread to
suppress the speech of media people I've
not seen any evidence that it is I feel
as though libel and slander laws are an
infringement on free speech but it's one
of the ones that we accept you know just
like how you can't make threats against
people
everyone always uses the example of
yelling fire at a crowded movie theater
it's just one of those things that it
doesn't qualify apparently there are
situations where you can yell fire in a
crowded movie theater I think that that
one I read a funny piece about that a
few weeks ago saying let's not even use
that example anymore I don't know what
example we should be using but well if
there is a fire obviously if there's a
fire but I guess even in some cases
where there isn't just yelling fire
would not actually be restricted by
limits on free speech it would be it has
to be the yelling of fire in conjunction
with a particular set of circumstances
I don't what am i - a phrase totally
cliche higher yeah in any case I think
that the infrastructure that we
currently have and the way in which
libel lawsuits can be used against
someone like Alex Jones has been wholly
appropriate I've seen no I've seen no
improper adjudication of those cases by
the legal system thus far and I'm
comfortable saying that the the victims
have been at least making attempt to use
it appropriately
right and of course the Sandy Hook
lawsuit is going on now yeah between the
family members of Sandy Hook victims and
Alex Jones we're saying they've been
maturely harmed
yeah and it's I think most clear in the
comic pingpong case where Alex Jones
went on and on for weeks about the pizza
gate scandal yeah and so some of his
followers took it upon themselves to
self investigate it was self investigate
yeah if someone brought a gun and shot
the place and of course they'd have to
spend so much money on security guards
and acting their business and of course
they took a hit from that no question
about it and if there are real material
damages that a libel lawsuit would
actually be appropriate if you disagree
with me I'm willing to have my mind
change who's the guy now that does those
things where he sets up shop and says
changed my mind
I blow if such and such that's steven
crowder steven crowder right I am
willing to have my mind change I have
seen no misuse of libel lawsuits against
media change my mind I'm ready to have
my mind change we've got a great bonus
show coming up for you today join
pakman.com patreon.com slash david
pakman show support the work that we do
and get access to the bone